oh the whole house is on my home
the whole surface oh what's going on
everybody for first week feast i'm shawn
evans and you're watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we welcome
adam richmond back to the hot seat
he's the travel channel legend you know
from shows like man vs food and the
best-selling books america the edible
and straight-up tasty
these days you can catch them on uk tv
supper man and the adam richmond's quest
for the best youtube channel
adam richmond welcome back to the show
what's going on buddy good to see you
good to see you too and you know you've
taken on some of the spiciest challenges
in the world including hot ones a time
before
is it like riding a bike are you feeling
some trepidation coming in here
no like some of these sauces are like
riding a bike without a seat
it's it's tough and in fact i want to
let everybody know
that last dab i thought i could just use
like a little bit because
the one that we did was really flavorful
this newest one was like that'll take
paint off your house
so i am legit terrified about this
season's
last dab this this joint right here oh
boy
[Music]
scary
[Music]
okay the classic how much how much is
like the amount you you say to edge on
[Music]
well you know in uh these quarantine
episodes
gus have been just dumping sauce all
over the wing so
my only like piece of advice is
for the love of god be careful okay i
respect that
oh jesus christ well this one's now
going to be a component
in all the rest of the wings okay
[Music]
we're getting slathery people we're
slathered
[Music]
so the pandemic has been a monumental
challenge for pretty much every sector
but especially the hospitality industry
which has not only had to fight to
survive
but also serve as de facto public health
officials trying to figure out how to
reopen
as someone who understands the
restaurant business better than most
are there things that stand out to you
that maybe the public doesn't fully
understand when it comes to the problems
facing restaurants right now
um i think that people
don't realize how many factors go into
the restaurant they think that you know
the point of sale is where the
restaurant experience kind of begins and
ends
but it starts at the supply chain there
was an issue in upstate new york
where farmers were used to restaurants
buying their produce buying in bulk
and then suddenly you know things go to
waste so there's a lot and the
restaurant
owners are really up against it and so
any initiative you can find to help the
hospitality workers i say go for it
and then this next question is not so
much about picking favorites but more
about supporting indie restaurants in
general
as a brooklyn og are there three iconic
brooklyn establishments that you think
need to be protected at all costs
because of their cultural significance
can i get five
can i get five children i know i did
this with you with my hip-hop mount
rushmore and i'm always like
give this guy a foot takes a mile but
um i'm going to say brennan and carr
the roast beef spot are no stronger than
you randazzo's
the best gala ma on edmonds avenue
juniors junior's cheesecakes you gotta
protect spimoni gardens
and uh nathan's i'm feeling very very
good which means that
by the time i hit the sauces at this end
i'm in very big trouble
[Music]
also really good sour it's almost like a
pickle juice vibe
but i'm into it so last time you were on
the show we talked about some of the
obvious parallels between man versus
food and hot ones but what's been even
more
fascinating to me is the way the adam
richmond name has been woven through the
fabric of hot ones in the time
since as an anglophile how big a deal
was it for you that noel gallagher gave
you a cosign that's not a guy who hands
out compliments very easily
that was and then you were kind enough
thank you it meant a lot that you were
like shout out adam richmond he's a
friend of mine and i remember
he goes busy oh [ __ ] it dude
and like what's the story morning glory
was a huge album for me personally
so the fact that you exist in the
consciousness of the mind of someone
who's affected your life so profoundly
just i don't know i was i was i was
chuffed to base i was really proud
and i have to say the fact that he's
sort of
it's unfortunately you know maybe threw
shade on the reboot but the fact that he
was more with my version of mvf then the
new one meant a lot to me too
especially because man versus food was
such a personal project for me
that the notion of someone else doing it
kind of hurts sometimes
hey i understand what you're saying
exactly when a complex inevitably
replaces me with like peter rosenberger
or some [ __ ] i'm going to be dancing on
the grave too
come on man i'm going to be and then
when i start a band with my imaginary
mancunian brother
i'm going to come on and go yeah i don't
really care for the new guy
no no no respect you know this display
whoever you are but
[Music]
um habanero is the one that always wakes
you up a little bit though and
yeah you're not just having a meal with
your buddy sean dude you're doing an
episode of hot ones
habanero's always the one that's like hi
remember me
see in a little bit with that hickory
hole from a culinary perspective
is the food in british soccer stadiums
ahead or behind
what they serve here in the united
states it's very much behind
i think the dining sensibilities
of an american sports goer and the
dining sensibilities of the average
football fan
are a little different because when it's
like pie and chips
or like burgers and stuff like that is
really all that's wanted maybe fish and
chips
well the drool is coming the jewel's
coming um
in america we have restauranteurs
curating everything we've got the danny
meyers of the world
i went to see a ball game in san
francisco and they have like hydroponic
herbs growing
denmark's national soccer team houses
the world's only
stadium restaurant that has a michelin
star it's called geranium and it dishes
out new nordic cuisine
what do you think about that like is
that visionary or is that pretentious
i think it's a great question
i think if it brings in new fans to the
game
it's visionary if it's just like oh my
god this place is so elite and so
whatever
and ignoring the match then i feel it's
like pretense
but when you have great players like
christian eriksen who's like a once in a
life once a generation type player
why would you why would you piss out
piss off an opportunity to
to see and play you know
all right hotter than l i will say once
again
shouts to hot ones in first we feast
these are like all flavor
and then the heat like the flavor on
that's really really really good
but now that one's like a lower heat
that one's sort of like right
in here ironically enough it's right
below the skull
you know how a null gallagher complement
means more because it's coming from noel
gallagher
a hot sauce curation compliment from
adam richmond means more because it's
coming from adam richmond
sean evans the [ __ ] dude
[Music]
so in 2019 you took part in history
channel's non-fiction miniseries the
food that built america
which highlighted the food barons and
empire builders that for better or worse
shape the way our country eats is there
a historical event or movement that you
think disproportionately affected the
way americans eat today
that's a great question i think to a
degree
world war ii because you had canning
was so prevalent for rations
um famously in cleveland uh chef hector
boyarty
yes jeff boyardee whose facilities had
gone
initially canning sea rats from military
suddenly you know was using it to make
canned shell stable pasta and
little known fact cheetos the way those
were created
the guy bought for a song powdered
cheese from the army when the war ended
they had an abundance of this powdered
cheese
so he made an extruded puffed corn snack
and then tossed it in like government
powdered cheese
so i think that the rapid
industrialization
of the world war ii era and i think the
surplus of
canning shipping lanes even things like
powdered cheese i think is a pretty big
thing but also i got to tell you i think
this quarantine is going to change a
whole lot of things i think as people
move out of urban centers
people like i'm grow i have a garden now
people growing their own thing baking
their own bread i think shit's going to
be very different
you know it's good because it's got the
logo on it
it's very tasty you guys did a great job
it's really good thank you adam this is
like a caribbean one
all right adam as you're acutely aware
we have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that gram where we do a
deep dive on our guests instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
i'll keep my answers shorter this time
what was it like uh chatting about
motorcycles with keanu reeves
whoa whoa so cool
he was incredibly kind and incredibly
sweet and he liked my jokes about
comparing his bikes to voltron and
asking if he was a fan of eero saanin's
architecture because of the lines of the
bike and literally he would do things
like i was saying
because your bike reminds me of eero
saarinen and he would turn around look
at me
and look away and go architecture
that was so dope but he was really
lovely and he was really patient and
then i think people were like
taking advantage with the pictures and
he was like
hasta la pasta why was meeting jeff
goldblum one of the best days of your
life
oh yeah sean paul
no he is the [ __ ] i did a lot of
research on him so when
i was walking off stage i'll never
forget this i had
you know checked my knees on plus make
sure the stove was good
i came down off the stage and there's
there's
jeff goldblum like coming up and he goes
oh
this isn't the favorite adam richman and
i went
if it isn't 412's finest which is
pittsburgh's area code i go this isn't
four one two as far as he goes
oh four one two pittsburgh
yes yeah and he couldn't be warmer
couldn't be nicer said take my number
responds to my text
and ironically enough i don't know if
you can see it in this camera
but that right there it's not like i had
a gang tattoo removed from my former
uh my former gang career that is a burn
that i sustained
during that cooking demo because someone
had turned the heat up
and i refer to it as my jeff goldblum
tattoo so he references it in the text
he sends me and stuff
but a nicer guy there is none an
unbelievable piano
player and the guy's got fashion sense
to burn
to burn best
[Music]
i i still talk about it like what an
honor it was to give you your very
well-deserved webby award
and ironically enough subsequent to your
well-deserved win
um you know because think about it you
were winning on the same night as hassan
minaj and issa rae
and jesus and mero and that was a nice
night but
you're very sweet you're very sweet to
give the speech adam i
i appreciated it i was honored to love
it and it was funny i've become somewhat
friendly with the kid marrow
and i told him i said i was backstage to
give you know your award and there's
michael douglas and stuff
and you know [ __ ] gordon gekko and
i'm like it's the bodega boys
that night was amazing and then i got to
meet the great tierra whack
which i no complaints okay this
is seafire gourmet
see fire come out of my ass who's
who thinks i'm sexy now all right
oh boy yep things are changing around
here
so since the travel channel and food
network wave that you were a part of
there's been an absolute explosion in
food programming from celebrities
launching their own youtube channels to
shows like ugly delicious and salt fat
acid heat trending on netflix
as an og in this space what excites you
about the current landscape of food
entertainment and what makes you want to
roll your eyes
[Music]
okay whoo i want to be able to talk this
is like the first time i'm legitimately
like
how many more do i have left three
[Music]
this one's rough sean i ain't gonna play
i'm trying to do too much milk like a
little [ __ ] okay what excites me
to me i've always felt that if food
becomes the domain
of the well-heeled the hyper-educated
then we're all kind of hopelessly
screwed action bronson
doing [ __ ] that's delicious the great
reyna scully who's on
first we feast doing gochee gang having
new voices
provides different access points you
bring a new audience in
if you get you know someone that lives
in washington heights that's of
dominican and puerto rican descent
seeing reina breaking down tonkatsu
and the intricacies and the
wonderfulness of japanese flavors that
can be found in manhattan
and it makes this person expand their
culinary horizons
dope and especially if it's done in the
way that
reina does it and the way that action
does it where it's fun
and it's a celebration what makes me
roll my eyes
is when it's this rich person or this
influencer
is now just trying to diversify their
platform
right i'm known for makeup tutorials but
i also really
love food oh the whole house is on my
hump
the whole surface oh oh this is
such a bad idea
that's a lot that's that's all is that
too much
well you tell me you've been saying that
people have been drenching it i want
people to be like yo adam richmond's a
little [ __ ]
yeah yeah but but i feel like it's been
[Music]
too
so urban gardening has been a la mode in
recent years and in these quarantine
times having that outdoor space it's
really a premium
and it seems like you've been really
embracing the green thumb these days
what are you growing in your garden
i'm growing basil two kinds of basil
spearmint and peppermint oregano
rosemary
jalapeno peppers which i'm gonna i'm
gonna burn every single one of them when
this is finished
man this is a [ __ ] show right here right
now
oh it's like deontay wilder just like
teed up actually more like
what uh
there are a lot of bizarre
do-it-yourself gardening tips that rank
from
you know giving seedlings a spot of
chamomile tea to prevent fungi
or leaving a can of beer out to attract
slugs away from the plants
are you doing anything outside the box
with your garden
it may be a little [ __ ] up but i think
it's actually quite holistic
i found a dead bird in my garden and i
felt i was like traumatized by it
like i felt horrible that it had
happened and um
i dug up one of the pots and i had just
gotten a bunch of bulbs
my mom and i actually gave it a little
bit of a bird funeral over face time
i planted soil and fertilizer over it
and put the bulbs in
and i must say those plants those
flowers
are growing at an exponential rate to
everything else
oh man is this the same [ __ ] that we had
the last time
yeah yeah be careful with that isn't
this the one that like
neil degrasse tyson was like this one's
about
this one there's so many experiences
well you know what neil degrasse tyson
knows what he's talking about with that
one be very careful
i remember this one this was the one
that i was just like
this has no flavor this is just penance
oh [ __ ] all right whatever i'm in it
i'm in it here we go
[Music]
oh
you've cooked with e40 you've cooked
with mike d and you understand the
cooking bonafides of people like
action bronson and trick daddy which
rapper do you think has the best
real deal chops in the kitchen that's a
great question probably action though
because he was an actual chef
and um he's got
you know oh he's got a lot of um
culinary experience he has a cookbook
and um he also picks up on a lot of
details as he travels
oh wow that one that one's really [ __ ]
after the other ones um
oh man
action like he's aware of things like
you need to put a cork
in with the octopus because it works
enzymatically to tenderize it
little things like that might escape uh
someone that is in a culinarian's eye
oh that was really bad dude
a hot debate throughout the history of
first we feast has always been about the
best rap food lyrics
i know your brain's on fire right now
and your mouth is ablaze but under these
conditions
are there any that stand out to you is
especially excellent
me and eric b are a great big plate of
fish which is my favorite dish but
without money is still a wish
that one is the first one to come to
mind i would say
um
gosh oh wait a minute uh oh my favorite
one
lil wayne real g's move in silence like
lasagna
the beastie boys i went to white castle
and i got thrown out why castle burgers
only come in one size
do you remember that guy gerardo
gerardo yeah he had that one song
rico yeah in the movie colors he's the
guy who shoots robert duvall at the end
he has a terrible lyric in that song
that
it's like no woman that can handle a man
like me i eat him raw like sushi
and i'm very mad at myself that that has
somehow occupied space in my brain
i don't like that at all
oh [ __ ] oh i didn't realize this [ __ ]
came out like that
is that too much yes every every wing
for you is too much but then at the same
time you're adam richmond so there's
i don't know what yeah i got like i got
a reputation to protect
you know and to me i always take on sort
of like a guardian role when it comes to
hot ones with celebrities like i never
want anybody to get hurt necessarily so
i'm always trying to protect them but i
guess with you i should just
witness greatness yeah okay but you're
pushing the envelope
oh
so one of my favorite adam richmond fun
facts is that you graduated from the
yale school of drama
and actually had a little bit of a
short-lived acting career before you
broke through on travel channel
between appearances on law and order all
my children
and joan of arcadia which particular
performance are you most proud of from
an acting perspective joan of arcadia
and the character was butcher god
so i was a butcher at the supermarket
and i was i was god and so
very often you know if you have an under
five role on a show
you're very seldom talking to a
principal character and if you are
you have two luck
[Music]
you have two lines but i had a scene
with amber tamblyn
for somebody who had just come out of
school it was just like super validating
in the end who won man
or food i think the director of the fact
that i'm still here and been able to
sustain a career
in food television for 11 years after
making my name with like
eight pound burgers and seven pound
burritos and stuff and being able to
show i could do more than that
you know i feel much like khalid
all i do is win win win no matter what
by the way i'm really upset with myself
for not calling out collard greens
for my rap lyric with kendrick okay
too much for a last dab
for all my fans and for hot ones fans
that enjoy
seeing me in pain and and i know you
you're a great interviewer you know
again our friendship aside i've always
appreciate your talent so
whatever you ask me i really want to be
able to make a proper [ __ ] of myself
during it
cheers my man
actually done bro appreciate the
technique okay adam richmond here we are
at the
end of your hot one sequel and we've
explored your polymath sensibilities
over nine wings and we just have one
more to go and to close things out what
we want to do is combine
your deep food expertise with a bit of
hot ones history
you're one of our first famous fans and
then now you're a fan favorite
and me sitting over here i've heard a
lot of crazy [ __ ] from the other side of
the table when it comes to food
intakes so what i want to do here is
bounce
some of the craziest food takes that
i've ever heard
while doing interviews on hot ones to
get the perspective
from adam richmond himself so we're
going to show you a circle here
i'm gonna have to let out the quarantine
long hair don't care vibes
all right all right on the topic of
burritos just last week
t payne said if you eat a burrito
sideways
it turns into a taco eventually it's a
great theory and it sounds
it's a good bumper sticker but like
maybe if you ate it like a corn on the
cob like typewriter style
my nose is on [ __ ] fire by the way
but like if you went cart like maybe
it's like a little bit of like a doe
canoe
host malone gave the nod to whataburger
over in and out
saying please bro in and out is like a
frilly little patty
i need something with some hair on its
chest cuz
animal style or not i just can't [ __ ]
with their fries but their burgers are
outstanding
and i i gotta think like
one and just musical profound musical
talents aside
you need to check yourself a little bit
because you are taking a lot of advice
from a guy with a lot of face tattoos
all right despite being from staten
island pete davidson claimed
that ellen b in brooklyn is the best
pizza in new york
it's the best sicilian slice i'll say
that if you want
oh
[Music]
sorry i just got that little lava drip
but also staten island there's that
place that he
works in in king of staten island
danino's that's supposed to be pretty
good
and they will they're a great restaurant
too the best in
all of the city within sicilian i'll say
yes but
there are other great pizzas well there
you have it
the final word from adam richmond and
look at you you champion
taking down the wings of death please
let me do the honor of rolling out the
red carpet for you my friend
this camera or possibly a camera be if
you've set one up
let the people know what you have going
on in your life thank you sean always
a great time being here thank you to
chris thank you to everyone at complex
and firstly feast
you guys have always treated me with
like lots of love and respect
and to the viewers there uh that's
everyone who ranks these uh
hot ones episodes that better make the
[ __ ] top ten and whoever handles the
social media account
i was super bummed i didn't make that
whole cafeteria meme
brett baker brett baker he's coming for
you broke my heart
um i have a brand new youtube channel um
adam richmond's quest for the best the
first series is um
the bisque biscuit reviews from an
american that you didn't even ask for
where i review british biscuit biscuits
from around the world actually
um and uh take them through a dunk test
also catch history channel
and for those of you in the uk adam
richmond supper man will be airing on
dave
and my brand new series which we'll be
shooting hopefully in november
if all goes well if all y'all wear masks
it is called
american made and that's also on the
history channel
great job adam great job thank you buddy
right now i'm probably gonna just have a
really
really rough night and and
be very grateful for moist moist
towelettes
what is up cam fam tis i the empire guy
bill for another hitoris hot ones
unboxing video
let's see what's inside
oh a sticker perfect for decorating
one's coffin
and what's this hot ones classic blue
label
garlic fresno edition now with ten ha ha
ha
times more garlic i can't do this
i can't do this can we cut i can't do
this do you see the problem with me
doing this
or the sound guy do you see the problem
i'm a vampire lit it's garlic
you can do this vampire guy bill you can
do this
hey that's delicious
[Music]
hot ones classic garlic fresno sauce so
good
even a vampire will try it only at
heatiness.com